If you suffer from headaches,
these glasses from the TikTok shop are everything.
You put them on.
I definitely get cluster headaches that will be,
like, on one side,
and they just,
like, bother me for days and days at a time.
And I really wanna sleep,
but I also really,
like, need some relief.
You put them on.
You put them on and they block out all light.
Obviously, all light.
You can close your eyes.
Not only that,
there's air pressure that feels like someone's rubbing your eye.
And then they come back over here and rub your temple.
And they rub your eye and they rub your temple.
It's got Bluetooth so you can play music.
This thing has brought me so much relief.
It's linked right here in the TikTok shop if you want one.